we have a Republican governor here in
Massachusetts I've mentioned him before
his name is Charlie Baker and he just
signed into law a bill giving every
resident of Massachusetts the option to
vote by mail in the fall and in the
primaries leading up to the fall if
indeed that is what we want to do now I
have not hidden this from folks since
the start of the corona virus pandemic I
did not vote for Charlie Baker I'm not a
Republican but he has been a Republican
who has done a good job a big picture on
the corona virus and he's doing a lot of
the right things so if I wanted to
criticize certainly he could have
started stay at home a little earlier he
could have talked about the importance
of wearing masks earlier but
Massachusetts is one of the few states
that has actually gotten the virus what
we would call under control as of right
now and this may change as cases
continue to explode in many states my
belief is that at some point because you
can't block travel between states or at
least it doesn't appear as though you
can because of the Constitution we are
going to have a bleed over effect I am
fully expecting that as we get into late
summer and early fall Massachusetts will
start to see more cases but as of right
now we've seen dramatic declines in
cases and much of it has been under or
related to Republican Governor Charlie
Baker's leadership and likewise we now
have a statewide vote by mail which is
extremely important and completely and
obviously logical given the corona virus
pandemic the Secretary of State website
now says quote in July meaning yesterday
a new law was passed to allow registered
voters in Massachusetts to vote by mail
in any twenty twenty election with no
excuse needed as required by the new law
a vote by mail application will be
mailed to every person who was
registered to vote by July 1 and who had
not already requested an absentee ballot
for the state primary or for all
elections this year a second mailing
will be sent out in September to all
voters who have not already applied for
vote by mail for the November election
the applications are pre addressed to
your local
official and no postage is necessary so
they're not just sending ballots around
the fear-mongering from the trumpian
right is you just start sending ballots
places anybody could fill them in and
return them and voter fraud and a little
that all that stuff the reality is what
they're doing is they're taking the list
of registered voters and sending them
applications for absentee ballots which
you still must return they must be
delivered to the local election office
no later than four business days before
the election this is the right move this
is simple just do it
come on States just do it it's the right
thing to do it's the safe thing to do
and the the problem is great
Massachusetts is doing it Biden is going
to win Massachusetts easily in other
words what I mean is the states that
will be close where people may be scared
to vote in person because of the
pandemic those are the states where you
might actually see a different outcome
if there isn't vote by mail and many of
those are the states that are not
interested in doing vote by mail now
fortunately there are important states
that have done it I believe Pennsylvania
and Ohio Arizona Texas has temporarily
said fear of catching the virus counts
as a valid reason to vote absentee maybe
Iowa but this needs to be something
every state does and and in fact when we
look at Trump careening down Hill in the
polls and we look at everything that's
going on his reelection depends on yes
lying about the state of the economy
lying about the state of the pandemic
but it also depends on suppressing the
vote and not allowing vote-by-mail is
something that could in very material
terms dissuade people from voting at all
back to Charlie Baker in Massachusetts
just just a little bit because I
anticipate some of the emails I might
receive I have no delusions that Charlie
Baker is the height of progressivism
he's a former health insurance CEO he's
like a Mitt Romney type Republican
essentially but it shouldn't be unusual
that you have a governor who listens to
doctors in science in other words what's
notable about the fact that Charlie
Baker a Republican governor has
mostly handled the virus correctly is
that it is unusual to have a Republican
governor who says I'm going to do what
the doctors recommend we have a pandemic
I'm going to make decisions based on
science and the medical community I'm
gonna close things I'm going to allow
vote-by-mail for everybody the reason
that this is newsworthy the reason that
I'm talking in these terms of we have a
Republican governor who has actually
managed this pretty well is that it's so
rare when you look at governor's like
Ron de santis in Florida I mean just off
the deep end Greg Abbott in Texas and in
particular it actually Abbott has come
back to reality a little bit saying we
need masks we should probably slow down
or stop on bars the Lieutenant Governor
there dan patrick has been particularly
crazy
you've got doug ducey in arizona and
many many others that is why it is so
notable that a republican governor like
Charlie Baker has done the right thing
now I have some criticisms of what
Charlie Baker is doing I believe it is
too early to do indoor dining phase
three in Massachusetts includes casinos
and movie theaters I just disagree I'm
not going to any of those I've decided
I'm comfortable with outdoor dining
right now I'm not going inside I mean
it's just it's not necessary it's summer
there are articles that are linking
card-present restaurant receipts
receipts to increased case numbers so it
does seem like the indoor dining is a
problem I think it's an unnecessary risk
right now particularly when we don't
mean listen there may not even be a gap
between wave 1 & 2 but we're
anticipating more cases in the fall so I
disagree with Baker on that I think it's
too early
big picture managing it well
vote-by-mail for everybody in
Massachusetts absolutely the right
decision I'm glad to see it we now just
need states where it'll be closed
between Trump and Biden to adopt it as
well the president and the harebrained
people around him are increasingly
fear-mongering around the stock market
saying if Biden wins in November say
goodbye to your 401ks here's actually a
tweet from Donald Trump yesterday where
he said quote if you want your 401ks and
stocks which are getting close to an
all-time high Nasdaq
already there to disintegrate and
disappear vote for the radical left
do-nothing Democrats and corrupt Joe
Biden massive tax hikes they will make
you very poor fast now I already dealt
yesterday with how the overwhelming
majority of Joe Biden's tax increases go
to the top one percent so I don't want
to get derailed here but remember my
segment about how populist rhetoric can
be used to bamboozle people Trump ran
with populist rhetoric he's for the
middle class and he's against all the
oppressive factors that are oppressing
the middle class Joe Biden's gonna raise
taxes on the very rich on the top 1% and
Trump populist Trump is now campaigning
against it and scaring people about it
doesn't sound very populist to me does
it anyway that's not what I want to deal
with today I want to look at this claim
Biden would be bad for the stock market
from a few different angles now the
first is just a reminder again they are
lying in the sense that the stock market
does better under Democratic presidents
I will get to that data in a moment but
the other side of this that I think is
always important to repeat when
something like this comes up is that the
Trump administration continues to say or
believe or claim or pretend that you can
measure how well an economy is doing by
looking at the stock market and you can
so before we even get into the numbers
of Democrats versus Republicans on the
stock market let me remind you stock
market performance does not tell you how
well the economy is doing stocks are
disproportionately owned by the wealthy
and by big corporations the more we
learn about how do we evaluate how well
or poorly an economy is doing we
understand that the stock market is a
component but it is merely one of many
components we should be looking at we
must look at the employment rate and
unemployment rate we have to look at
wage growth we have to look at the
quality of jobs we must look at
inflation and inequality and really you
want to look at quality of life factors
as well what is life expectancy
educational factors where is literacy
right there are so many ways to figure
out like how is a country doing a big
picture but let's for a second green
them that there is an empirical reality
stock markets either do better under
Democratic presidential administrations
or Republican presidential
administrations we can measure it we can
know this there are a whole bunch of
different ways to do it so you've got to
make some decisions like I'll give you
some examples do you would just stock
market for a performance for inflation
or not when comparing Democratic and
Republican performance do you calculate
returns with dividends reinvested or not
okay so there's like little tweaks in
terms of how you calculate it no matter
how you do it every serious analysis
finds that stocks do better under
Democratic presidents than they do under
Republican presidents if you go back to
1929 on average stocks make about 10% a
year during democratic presidencies and
about 2% a year during Republican
presidencies that's one study from
Forbes another study that looked only at
the last 45 years or so found that the
stock market return is about 14 percent
per year under Democratic presidents ten
percent per year under Republican
presidents now the difficulty of these
numbers is that you can have sort of
outlier years that can skew the averages
but from an empirical historical
perspective the stock market does better
when there's a Democrat in the White
House instead of a Republican but that's
looking back okay we then should analyze
if we want to do this thoroughly would
changing from Trump to Biden likely
raise the value of stock prices lower
the value or make no change whatsoever
very interesting new research from JP
Morgan which finds that if you look at a
Biden replacement of Trump it would
either be neutral or slightly positive
in terms of stock prices and they also
mentioned that adding a quote diplomatic
approach could be good for stocks in
that it would reduce volatility now this
is funny because you know it's JP
morgen they're trying to just make it
adjust the facts analysis they don't
want to be political diplomatic approach
is a polite term for Biden will be more
normal
right Biden will not constantly do crazy
stuff markets like normal markets like
less volatility and the other component
that's more of an intangible if we think
about the effective Biden replacing
Trump on the stock market is a Biden
presidency would better deal with
coronavirus and because coronavirus is
really the major drag on the economy
right now there are additional benefits
we would expect to the economy from Joe
Biden taking over for Donald Trump we
interestingly we saw this under Bush
Obama the economy cratered under george
w bush of course 9/11 was a part of it
but certainly going to war with a
country that didn't attack us did not
help helped some defense stocks but it
did not help the economy overall
we saw the mortgage crisis devolve into
the 2007-2008 recession and then barack
obama came in and operated in January of
2009 and started to clean it up could
have better cleaned it up for sure
didn't do everything right but that was
the way when we could end up with a very
similar dynamic under Trump Biden if
Donald Trump is actually removed in
November and made a one-term president
not a guarantee but something that could
happen we could see a similar dynamic
where we see a proper economic recovery
once again under a Democratic president
it remains to be seen but the point is
the argument that Biden would be worse
for stocks than Trump it doesn't fit the
historical realities of stock markets
under Democrats versus Republicans and
it doesn't even pass the sniff test when
you think about replacing kooky wild
wacky Donald Trump with someone in Joe
Biden who would be no progressive hero
but would certainly bring back diplomacy
and bring back some stability and bring
back some sanity big day next Tuesday
we've got two huge things going on next
Tuesday it will be the third David
Pakman show chess tournament 8:00 p.m.
Eastern you can sign up now at david
pakman.com slash chess this is totally
free I will be
playing we had over seven 700 players
during the June tournament hope to do
better than that sign up for free at
david pakman.com slash chess number two
we lost like 300 members in the last
week because we had a membership special
last year when those memberships came up
for renewal this year because of the
virus a lot of people couldn't afford to
renew so sadly we had like our worst 72
hours of my ever so next Tuesday the
same day as the chess tournament we're
gonna do a 1-day membership special if
you want to be notified of it just get
on my newsletter at david pakman.com
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more right after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Don cupid oh
and Faye Schofield Don and Faye thank
you for your support and a big special
thank you to Michael Henderson Michael's
been a member for almost five years hard
to believe
thank you Michael you are today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
grab a membership at join pakman.com
quick easy and you get the daily award
winning only awards we give out but
still award-winning bonus show every
single day so months ago I told you that
the White House and Donald Trump are
trying to normalize coronavirus deaths
so that they're just not notable anymore
yeah people are dying people are dying
from corona virus every day but we're
sort of moving on and this it's hard to
pinpoint exactly when it started but
certainly it was a very clear decision
that was made when Donald Trump wondered
aloud about injecting bleach and
isopropyl alcohol to treat corona virus
that was where it was like very clear
these are really doing much more damage
these press briefings than they are
helping anybody in the Trump
administration and so they stopped the
daily press briefings and they
essentially considered that they had
defeated the invisible enemy or as
Donald Trump often calls it the
invisible scourge Trump stopped talking
about it talked exclusively about the
stock market reopening how we've won and
there's therapeutics and vaccines on the
way we stopped seeing doctors vouch Ian
Burks on any kind of regular basis and
Trump increasingly distanced himself
from the even medical claims that doctor
foutch II would make and one of the
themes of the Trump administration
bigger picture has been hyper
normalization and that's exactly what
they're trying to do with coronavirus
hyper normalization is the making normal
of things that should not be seen as
normal including the weekly or near
daily scandals that we've seen during
this administration the way in which
Trump talks to people and uses
xenophobic and racist dog whistles and
has made fun and both of and bullied
just about everybody and I've admitted
that even for me because I'm in this
stuff and covering this stuff every day
I have to go out of my way to remind
myself even though the 20 of these
things happen this week none of them is
normal if any one of these things that
happened during Barack Obama's
presidency they would be one-week
scandals on fox news that gets us to the
new reports coming out of the White
House and these are reports from people
close to the Trump campaign and the
Trump administration the new goal is and
it's like of course we knew this they
want to reframe the coronavirus they
want to make the exploding number of
cases and also the for now lower but
still significant number of deaths the
new normal
make people numb to the numbers if you
hear that 400 people died every day
eventually it sort of becomes I hate to
use this analogy like kids dying of
hunger in Africa right eventually it
becomes not about the individuals that
becomes a number and we're sort of used
to the number there's gun violence and
people die from from gun for from gun
violence and we're not going to stop
selling people guns as the gun people
have said and people kids are dying of
hunger in Africa every day but we're
still gonna continue to throw out 30% of
our food or whatever it is right as the
phrases phrase often goes and you know
400 people died of coronavirus but were
essentially numb to it is the goal from
the Trump administration and there's a
reason that Donald Trump talks about it
less and less other than to claim
victory which is his campaign realizes
that coronavirus is a loser of a topic
for him this is one of the reasons why
his approval rating has imploded his
handling of the virus the associated
economic
handling and recently the reaction to
the protests against police brutality so
the focus will continue to be economic
recovery jobs CEOs fast food restaurants
opening and make the cases and deaths
the new normal we can live with the
virus schools should reopen that's a
focus now there should be professional
sports we'll have a vaccine any day now
everybody should just keep doing more
and more stuff even if the case numbers
keep increasing even if we're hitting
weekly new case records a week in and
week out and if we end up with an
escalating death toll that some expect
in the next month I'm going to have a
bigger report tomorrow about the
increase in cases without yet an
increase in deaths but we may still get
that in the next month hopefully we
won't but the Trump administration idea
is if we stop talking about it if we
stop highlighting it maybe Trump's base
will at least move on and maybe the
media will start to move on the idea is
the public will accept 50,000 cases a
day maybe even a hundred thousand cases
a day if the numbers go in that
direction because eventually there will
be a vaccine and a treatment people will
become numb to the numbers and we've got
to keep the economy open so my message
to you is we can't let them make that
this story right Trump has failed hugely
on the virus they are doing this they're
trying to normalize the rapid spread of
the virus because they recognize that
the virus could be what removes Donald
Trump from office in the November
election
Trump's approval rating on dealing with
coronavirus is in the toilet
voters overwhelmingly prefer Joe Biden
to trump in terms of who would would
Biden better deal with coronavirus than
Trump has if we could identify the one
moment where it really went bad I keep
going back to what about if we hit the
body with isopropyl alcohol and and
bleach and then from there it's been
very much downhill and if the numbers
don't turn around the only choice they
have is let's normalize it let's make
people numb to it let's make believe
that this is just normal
and notice that we talked about that
phrase an ounce of prevention is cheaper
than a pound of cure simply dealing with
the virus properly from day one would
have been both much simpler and much
less costly in terms of money and lives
then now trying to lie to people to get
them to vote for you we would have saved
lives we would have almost seen a
guaranteed Trump reelection if Trump had
handled it well if Trump had actually
dealt with coronavirus starting on
January 20th remember South Korea got
their first case on January 20th so did
we maybe because of the time difference
it was the 19th and the 20th but within
hours of each other South Korea and the
u.s. got our first cases the u.s. had
low testing and high spread where is
South Korea immediately developed the
test contact traced isolated people we
could have had high testing lower spread
fewer cases fewer deaths and it would be
really tough for Joe Biden right now if
Trump had demonstrated leadership by
really dealing with the virus
I don't know that Biden's polling +12
nationally if that's the case prevention
is cheaper than cure avoiding the
situation getting so bad to begin with
would have been way easier than now
trying to fix it and when I say fix it I
mean both electoral E and in terms of
the virus if you look at Florida Texas
in Arizona it's essentially out of
control you're looking now at months to
reduce those case numbers just like it
took that long in Massachusetts and in
New York and in other places so just a
reminder in 2014 when two Americans died
of Ebola Republicans were demanding
Obama's head on a stick we now have over
a hundred and thirty thousand deaths in
the United States and the Trump strategy
is normalize it and pretend that that's
just the way things have to be and I
cannot skip this important piece sorry I
hit my mic because I'm getting so wound
up this goes back to the failures of the
educational system in the US and and the
cultural failures as well especially
among the right when it comes to anti
intellectualism if you know even a
little bit more about medicine science
statistics critical thinking
epistemology media literacy a ton of the
disinformation that
spreads about the virus would never
spread some of it would but a lot less
of it would spread if you are slightly
more educated you don't fall for record
job creation in June 4.8 million jobs if
you're slightly more educated you
realize wait a second
we lost 47 million jobs we got 4.8
million back we're really in bad shape
what what the hell is Trump talking
about but unfortunately people do fall
for it so part of this is education part
of it is you have a willing audience
that wants to repeat anything that Trump
says for political reasons and that's
where we end up today now very very last
thing even if Americans grow numb to the
cases and the deaths I don't know that
they will grow numb to being evicted I
don't know that they will grow numb to
not having money to pay their bills or
to not having a job so that is something
that will be tougher to normalize for
the Trump administration we'll just have
to see how it goes this is a hilarious
and sad and tragic and completely
predictable story all at once Fox News
remove Donald Trump from a picture with
Jeffrey Epstein and ghilane Maxwell now
he Lane Maxwell yeah I just because I
mentioned their names this video will be
demonetised but it's an important story
he Lane Maxwell is the former girlfriend
of the late Jeffrey Epstein allegedly
the recruiter of many of the women who
apps teen is accused of sexually
assaulting and after a long I guess you
could call it an absence at least from
the public eye Maxwell has been arrested
and is scheduled to be in court this
Friday now Donald Trump is very
connected to Jeffrey Epstein we have
countless pictures of them together
there's the video of Trump and Epstein
sort of evaluating young women who were
dancing at a party during the 1990s
Trump and Epstein were accused of rape
by the same then 13 year old girl that
case was eventually dropped take a look
at this video in which Fox News is doing
a story about the arrest of a Gillian
Maxwell and they actually Photoshop out
they just cropped Trump out of a picture
with Epstein and it just a disclaimer
this there's this is very visual so if
you're just listening you're only going
to hear what they are saying but what
you
see on screen is Melania Trump than
nouse I believe before she was married
Guylaine Maxwell Epstein and then
there's just somebody who's been cropped
out and that's Donald Trump take a look
at this against Maxwell which one are
you focused on most and how does the
timeline of all three play out well
thank you for having me and that's a
very we've we call it we call that a
compound question there's a lot going on
in that question to kind of decompress
but yeah I would say that all three of
those things are there three different
areas that we're all looking at
obviously we have the civil case against
Epstein the criminal case against miss
Maxwell that now if you look at the
original picture which is widely
available of course you see the four of
them it's Trump along with Melania and
Jeffrey Epstein and ghilane Maxwell so
clearly this is an attempt to rewrite
history and remove the friendship of
Trump and Epstein right well Fox says it
was just an innocent mistake didn't mean
to just an accident
check this out they put out a quote
saying on Sunday July 5 a report on
Guylaine Maxwell during Fox News
Channel's America's News headquarters
mistakenly eliminated President Donald
Trump from a photo alongside Melania
Epstein and Maxwell we regret the error
it was just a coincidence right it was
they mistakenly cropped exactly Donald
Trump out of that picture how do you
mistakenly edit someone out of a picture
and not notice that the person you
happen to edit out is the President of
the United States right now and one
thing that's actually a little weird to
me is that Fox used that picture to
begin with why even use that one because
there's plenty of stock photos all over
the place of Epstein with Elaine Maxwell
and someone emailed me an interesting
hypothesis which is you know why they
did this David they picked a picture
that Trump was in but cropped him out to
intimidate Trump Trump's been going hard
at fox news lately saying that they're
falling you know that you got to watch
news max in a way and Fox is bad now Fox
is sending Trump a message we have
pictures of you with Epstein
okay we're cropping you out this time
but if you keep going after us this is
the hypothesis will put out the pictures
where you're not cropped out I don't
know it's an interesting idea is it Fox
trying to portray Trump more positively
by cropping him out is it Trump being
protected by Fox News is it an
intimidation signal we don't really know
but what is important to remember is
that these were people who were around
each other frequently Maxwell now has
been moved to the Metropolitan Detention
Center in Brooklyn New York scheduled to
appear in court on Friday now I just I
want to get this out of the way now if
Maxwell is found dead while in custody
and it appears she committed suicide
there would be no doubt that something
is up right are people on board with me
on this one I'm just getting it out
ahead of time just in case and of course
we hope that that doesn't happen just
want to think ahead as to what your
reaction would be if that were to take
place will have continued coverage of
crop gate on our Instagram page at David
Pakman show and if you want something
lighter
there is a full tour of my backyard
urban gardener on my Instagram page
right now at david.com the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show it's great to welcome
to the program today Daniel Markovitz
who's a professor of law at the Yale Law
School and also author of the book the
meritocracy trap how America's
foundational myth feeds inequality
dismantles the middle class and devours
the elite Daniel so great to have you on
today it's a real pleasure to be here
thank you for doing this so maybe maybe
just to start with let's start with what
what maybe is the top line story that's
often told which is the great thing
about America is that it's a meritocracy
everybody has a chance at making it if
they are whatever enough committed
enough if they want it enough regardless
of background or economic status etc how
can we evaluate the truth or falsity of
that sort of top line story yeah great
so what you've done is you've identified
what makes meritocracy so attractive it
seems like it gives everybody a fair
shot at success if they just have the
hard work and talent and it seems that
it produces an elite that's really
capable because it's proved itself in
competition and for a while meritocracy
worked that way in its early years it
broke up an old hereditary aristocracy
but then what happened is that people
who got to the top through meritocracy
themselves turn out to have an almost
unbounded taste and talent for training
their children and so the elite today
invests so much more in educating as
children than anybody else can possibly
afford to do an education works which
means that when you measure young people
based on their academic accomplishments
it's the kids of rich parents who do
best and meritocracy then
Pech awaits itself and creates a new
kind of aristocracy just based on
degrees rather than breeding and that
sort of assumes that there is at least
some zero-sum nature to elements of our
society in the economy right I mean if
one wanted to play devil's advocate they
could say great once someone through
their work achieves they become good at
training their kids and their can say
then that's fine as long as everybody
else is not disadvantaged as a result of
that then it would still be ok right so
I think there are two there are two
responses to that that's I think that's
a powerful point the first is there is
inevitably some zero-sum competition so
that education is a you know rank good
and the value of my education depends on
how much education the person behind me
in the job line has but the other deeper
point is that this new elite has
fundamentally reconstructed the way our
economy works the way we deliver
services the way we make goods so that
the new economy privileges specifically
the narrow set of elite skills that
fancy education is give and D values all
other skills so that the rich today when
they succeed more nearly push everybody
else down then drag to draw everybody
else up so if we concede that certainly
we we don't have a full meritocracy I
think before we explore some of the
specifics in more detail it might be
interesting to consider what if what a
true meritocracy really be the ideal in
and we can approach that from a few
different perspectives but maybe just
I'll start with that question what what
would be good about an actually
meritocratic society and what might be
not so good yeah so from my perspective
I want to be clear a full meritocracy
would not be the ideal it would be more
nearly a nightmare um what would be good
about it though and it has some good
things is that it would undermine all
sorts of hierarchies and inequalities
that are morally awful hierarchies based
on race or caste or gender or sexual
orientation or ethnicity those are all
despised by Meritage
and one of the reasons why meritocracy
is so attractive is that it works to
undermine those on the other hand what
it would also do is it would create a
new hierarchy based on training based on
how much training your parents could buy
for you and it would produce incredibly
unequal outcomes and if there's one
lesson of the book that I think is
really important to drive home it's that
the idea that equality of opportunity
can make unequal outcomes okay is a
moral mistake and what we need is more
equality of outcomes in our world can
you say more about that because it might
I mean that we have even though my
audience is mostly on the Left I think
that there's probably a range of
opinions in terms of the degree to which
equality of opportunity would be the
goal versus equality of outcome can you
talk a little bit more about because the
quality of outcome can mean a lot of
different things and and maybe as to
contextualize it one of the things that
seems immutable in humanity is that
there is rarely exact distribution in
any field or venture that mirrors the
makeup of society whether it's in terms
of gender race age whatever right so if
we start with that reality a quality of
outcome can sound pretty scary in some
ways yeah sure and it's also important
to say I'm not and I don't think
anybody's serious is in favor of
absolute equality of outcome you know
the way in which like pro crustose used
to chop people off if they were to long
for the Betty stuck them in that that's
a deeply dangerous notion but right now
we have so much inequality of outcome
that it's hard really to recognize how
extreme it is the richest 1% of
Americans today control a greater share
of the nation's income and wealth then
for example a comparable elite did in
ancient Rome during the era of Imperial
decadence so we have inequality of
outcome that is just extravagantly
skewed and when that happens
elites use what
ever selection mechanism there is to
privilege their own kids and so when you
get sufficiently big inequality of
outcomes you can't have a quality of
opportunity just to give you a way of
thinking about that very quickly in our
country today if you take the difference
between what a typical 1% household
invests in educating its children and
what a typical middle-class household
invests so not a poor household but a
middle-class household and every year
you take that difference and you put it
in the S&P 500 to create an inheritance
that will go to the rich kids when their
parents die that would be well north of
10 million dollars per child and that
produces a massive skew in who gets
ahead and it's driven by the inequality
of outcomes in the prior generation and
that's unjust has has this been a change
in the last 20 or 30 years and by that I
mean a change in the direction of less
conspicuous spending by the very rich
let less about things that immediately
show wealth like what you know watches
or expensive cars or whatever the case
but a type of spending on education and
upbringing that maybe has a more
pervasive effect in perpetuating
inequality well I think two things have
happened and the underlying driver of
this is the rich have just gotten so
much richer so one thing that's happened
is that the rich are actually spending
more on consumption and luxury kinds of
goods than they used to but because
there are no sit now so many rich people
they don't stand out in the same way
there are whole enclaves there are whole
super structures built to serve as rich
consumption you know they're
increasingly someplace they have
separate airline terminals for the
richest passengers so you don't see them
but it's also the case as you say that
no part of consumption inequality has
grown faster than inequality in spending
on education and absolutely enormous
when we think about so to go back a
little bit because I think this might be
an interesting area and oh I should
mention we've been speaking with Daniel
Markovitz we're gonna go to a break on
the TV radio and podcast episode but the
conversation will continue and pull on
our YouTube channel
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
the right loves to say that the left is
waging a culture war rather than an
issues based war but I am going to make
the case today that it is effectively
the Donald Trump administration that is
actually doing that the last 12 hours on
Twitter for Donald Trump have been very
very wacky he will not or cannot stop
lying he seemed to defend the
Confederate flag he tweeted more racism
including referring to Indian Elizabeth
Warren and the context of all of this as
Trump's approval is down to 38 percent
Trump is losing by an average of seven
in Michigan losing by six in Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania losing by five in
Florida losing by three in Arizona and
he's just falling apart visibly publicly
and embarrassingly and we're going to go
through just a couple of these elements
and then circle back to the culture war
component Trump continued his
empirically demonstrable lies related to
coronavirus which is of course spreading
as I told you yesterday we are seeing
pretty dramatic approval cratering for
Trump in the most affected counties by
coronavirus Trump tweeting quote why
does the lamestream fake news media
refuse to say that China virus deaths
are down 39% and that we now have the
lowest fatality mortality rate in the
world they just can't stand that we are
doing so well for our capital C country
now this is just not true about the
mortality rate we have the ninth highest
per capita death rate in the world out
of more than 200 countries and
territories ninth highest if you don't
include tiny countries like San Marino
and Andorra the US has the seventh
highest per capita death rate in the
world so Trump is lying now in terms of
the decrease in deaths I'm glad we've
seen a trending down in deaths there's a
bunch of possibilities still on the
table the deaths haven't happened
because of a lag time they would start
this week presumably we already saw
yesterday Texas tie their record high
for single day deaths could be a less
deadly strain that's a possibility
although we don't actually have evidence
for that yet there could be states that
are
about the death toll could be younger
folks lately getting the virus who are
less likely to die could mean that more
testing is leading to more tests for
people who are less sick which is going
to reduce that comparative death rate we
just don't know yet but what we are
seeing at least in Texas is that those
death numbers are starting to go up then
Trump moved on to talking about
Elizabeth Warren Donald Trump of course
focusing lately on statues and sports
team names tweeting quote they name
teams out of strength not weakness but
now the Washington Redskins and
Cleveland it Indians to fabled sports
franchises look like they are going to
be changing their names in order to be
politically correct Indians like
Elizabeth Warren must be very angry
right now I'm not even going to insult
your intelligence by doing an analysis
of that one I think you all get the
wackiness of that one and then on to the
Confederate flag tweeting quote has
Bubba Wallace apologized to all of those
great NASCAR drivers and officials who
came to his aid stood by his side and
were willing to sacrifice everything for
him only to find out that the whole
thing was just another hoax that and
flag decision has cost lowest ratings
ever so what Trump is referring to there
is that NASCAR made a decision that the
Confederate flag would not be allowed at
their events it won't be allowed in the
crowd it won't be allowed on cars or in
team areas or whatever Trump says that
is why ratings are down for NASCAR so
question one is were people really
tuning into NASCAR for the Confederate
flag because if so that would be really
weird but next what I want to get to is
that when this came up during Kaylie
McKenna knees press briefing yesterday
again a really bad day for Trump once
again reportedly Trump is watching more
TV than ever and and is in his own world
Kaylie McKenna knee refused to even say
whether Trump is indeed saying he
supports the Confederate flag here or
not and that's what I want to talk about
next
so this is really interesting Donald
Trump tweeted about the Confederate flag
in the context of NASCAR and it became a
really big topic at yesterday's press
briefing with Donald Trump's press
secretary Kaley mcenany so just to
refresh refresh you a little bit on
these press briefings they start very
late they are very very short few
questions are taken and they almost
always end with a scripted walk off line
from Caylee Mackin Annie they want these
to be sort of like Mike drop moments the
trumpets love them I cringe when I see
them and yesterday the topic of Donald
Trump's tweet about the Confederate flag
was a big topic of conversation just to
refresh the tweet once again Trump
tweeting yesterday has Bubba Wallace
apologized to all of those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and were willing
to sacrifice everything for him only to
find out that the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused the lowest ratings ever so as a
result of the tweet a bunch of questions
yesterday about it does Trump want the
Confederate flag in more places
is Trump supporting the Confederate flag
and Kaleigh Mac and Annie kept repeating
Trump isn't making a judgment one way or
the other about the flag which of course
is exactly the problem we want to hear
Trump's opinion on the flag here's one
question asked yesterday
kilee to follow up on Peters question
what is the president's position does he
think NASCAR made a mistake by banning
the Confederate flag so he said he I
spoke to him this morning about this and
he said he was not making a judgment one
way or the other the intent of the tweet
was to stand up for the men and women of
NASCAR and the fans and those who have
gone and this rush to judgment of the
media to call something a hate crime
when in fact the FBI report concluded
this was not an intentional racist act
and it very much mirrors other times
when there have been a rush to judgment
let's say with the Covington boys or
with Jesse Smollett so she won't answer
she says Trump told me you know Caylee
I'm not making a judgment one way or the
other obviously that didn't happen they
are making a calculated optics decision
not to say one way or the other if you
ask me of course I just say yeah I'm
against the Confederate flag
being displayed Jonathan Karl from ABC
News tries a second time to get an
answer about the flag because Cayley
continues to try to obfuscate and talk
about other things didn't go much better
let's drill down on the Confederate flag
does he think it was a mistake
for NASCAR to ban the president said he
wasn't making a judgment one way or the
other you're focusing on one word at the
very bottom of a tweet that's completely
taken out of context and neglecting the
complete rush to judgment our ratings
were down because they banned the fly
that's what he said and the president
was noting the fact that in aggregate
this notion that NASCAR men and women
who have gone and who are being demeaned
and called racist and being accused in
some venues of committing a hate crime
against an individual those allegations
were just dead wrong so again she won't
answer and she insists Trump is not
judging the Confederate flag one way or
the other well that's the problem Caylee
what we're trying to do is figure out
what is Trump's position on the
Confederate flag is Trump actually so
desperate for the racist vote that he's
afraid to denounce the Confederate flag
or play coy at least with it the answer
appears to be yes now just for reference
this is really interesting for two
reasons I found a video of Trump five
years ago talking about the Confederate
flag Confederate monuments the video is
fascinating for two reasons number one
Trump very clearly says it should be
taken down and put in a museum he just
says it very clearly unequivocally the
other thing that's interesting is Trump
sounds far more articulate and coherent
take a look at the video you're the lone
Republican presidential candidate who
has yet to weigh in on whether or not
you think the Confederate flag should be
flying above the Statehouse in South
Carolina do you think it needs to go I
think it probably does and I think they
should put it in the museum let it go
respect whatever it is that you have to
respect because it was a point in time
and put it in a museum but I would take
it down yes so that is not a donald
trump who still exists number one that
donald trump doesn't exist and that
trump is no longer willing to say it
should just be put away in a museum it's
not it doesn't have a place out in
public the Confederate flag Trump is
also not nearly as lucid and coherent as
he was five years ago so
Kaleigh Mackey and Annie now can't say
this they realize I guess that they need
the racist confederate vote but more
importantly I want to mention this
culture war component here here's for me
the really important takeaway from this
the right loves to accuse the left of
fighting a culture war it's Trump who
has lost on every substantive policy
issue and now has been relegated to
making the issues of the last two weeks
statues and monuments Confederate once
Confederate flags sports team names
NASCAR and claiming that he's fighting
radical anarchist Marxists who of course
don't exist
that's the hill apparently they're
choosing just to to not necessarily die
on but to plant a flag on to keep to use
the metaphor and that is the culture war
right I mean we on the Left are talking
about coronavirus science medical policy
public health the economy tax plans the
failures of our health care system
foreign policy they are the ones making
it about this now I know you can say
well but there are people on the Left
who are trying to take down the
monuments okay that is not the big issue
on the left it has been almost
exclusively the issue of Trump for the
last ten days maybe this is an
oversimplification but intangible issues
are easier to claim victory on you can't
claim that you replaced Obamacare like
you promised because you didn't you
can't claim victory on the virus even
though they've sort of been trying to
because people see the numbers with
stuff like defending our monuments and
our culture I guess you can try to claim
victory I don't know if it'll work hey I
got a funny voice mail at two one nine
to david p about my pronunciation of a
city in oklahoma take a listen hey thank
you for listening to this I'm a listener
and I love your show I just wanted to
let you know that I watched the episode
where Trump was at Mount Rushmore and
said lots of things incorrectly and when
you announced that he was at Tulsa
Oklahoma you said to us so you might
wanted to go back and correct that just
so nobody catches written
everything bad about you absolutely
delightful voicemail people will say bad
things about me either way it's just an
inside joke going back to the Tulsi
Gabbard Tulsi days
I'm just mispronouncing it in the same
it's just it's a dumb inside joke and I
apologize if anybody was upset by it but
you know I I know that it's pronounced
Tulsa Oklahoma but just to get us back
to the days of the Democratic primary
I've been having a good time calling it
tool sup but I know that it's Tulsa
I appreciate it anyway okay next Tuesday
David Pakman show chess tournament 8:00
p.m. Eastern sign up for free today at
david pakman.com slash chess and next
Tuesday one day membership special to
try to recover some of the 300 lost
memberships of the last week get
notified about both the chess tournament
and the membership special by getting on
our newsletter at david pakman.com i'll
see you on the bonus show which are
existing members of course already have
access to